some people are insanely adventurous
we're about 12 hours away from any
hospital
they enjoy taking risks just for fun and
excitement
meet these sensation seekers whose love
of adrenaline will make you dizzy
[Music]
every year the world's most elite
mountain bikers gather in france for a
race unlike any other
it's
the longest
tony race in the world
that's right mcavalanch is the longest
downhill race in the world 18 miles long
10 000 feet high in the french alps and
a crazy starting line of 3 000 cyclists
on a mountain peak this is remy absalon
he won the mcavalanche
i started mountain bike when i was young
enduro and mountain bike is
really cool because we can explore all
around the world
mecca avalanche alperus takes place
since the french alps in halperduez so
not so far of italy and switzerland
it's
really high in harps so you have a
very good
view 360 degrees
around you
it's really crazy i don't know why
i do that
you ride all kind of terrain first the
glacier and after the rocky section the
forest
is very physical with
some herpes so when you cross the line
and you are first
you're you're really happy and
you want to try again
[Music]
i kind of compare it with being at a
giant
dog park some of them love it like you
start giving them armpit scratches and
they're just like giant dogs they just
start rolling around and they're flying
all around you but these animals are
huge
people are intimidated by them but once
you once you learn their behavior
they're just right into you right away
they just look at you like a big chew
toy
[Music]
i could never see myself living anywhere
other than the pacific northwest
i could literally spend every single day
the rest of my life and never travel
anywhere other than vancouver island and
i would still never have enough time to
see this whole place
my first introduction to the ocean would
have definitely come from my mom just me
the sea lion right there
later on in life realize it is a pretty
unique experience to get to out and
spend time with these animals on a
regular basis
sea lions are of large
intelligent animal and they're very
sensitive of what your intentions are
and and how they choose to interact with
you is totally their choice
if you're comfortable and and they're
inquisitive they'll come and they'll
chew on your fans or they come up and
they chew on the edge of your mask or
give you big kisses on the lips or big
hugs they wrap their fins around you and
give you a big hug
[Music]
people get sketched out about it
like i've had lots of people contact me
and be like don't you think those things
are aggressive
just because in animals putting its
mouth on you doesn't mean it's doing it
in a harmful way they don't have hands
they can't explore their world
with anything other than their mouth
people that spend
a lot of money to travel to the other
side of the planet to watch a group of
large migratory animals in africa or
something say and here i can just go out
on my boat and it's not something i take
for granted at all anymore having the
opportunity to do this
[Music]
the ultra 6633 is a 352
mile long race across the arctic
it's cold it didn't really get above -45
it's long
i think that took me 150 hours
and most people
don't finish it
this is dave barrage he lives on the
isle of wight it's a small island off
the south coast of england
and last year he won the ultra 6633
so i'm talking to him about what it
feels like to race across the arctic
a typical marathon is 26.2 miles long
so this is like 14 of them back to back
the distance is isolating you're on your
own for like two days at a time
and with negative 45 degree temperatures
it feels even longer
everything up there is big there's just
nothing to gauge distant spies nothing
to judge anything by
you can see nothing but white
so you start to think am i asleep or am
i dreaming this when am i actually
moving it's like being in a painting
it took dave six days to finish the race
and he only slept
a total of ten hours
it's that exhaustion he says that causes
you to lose your mind
your mind just starts imagining all
sorts i've went through
an avenue of trees and i thought i was
going through a disco party and every
time i approached somebody
they stopped talking and just looked at
me
but you can't stop
you've got to keep moving you think what
on earth is that coming towards me and
you know within two minutes you're
shivering you shouldn't have stopped
to look at something that's not there
i achieved what i wanted to achieve and
i finished it and i'm very grateful and
very lucky to have finished it
of all the races i've done it's one of
the most mentally challenging races out
there and it's probably the race that
commands the most respect
anybody who finishes that will well i
would certainly
they've got my admiration
oh yeah
a lot of people's reactions when we told
them were going to go basically to the
north pole or ride mountain bikes where
are you bringing ice tires you know
because most people think in the north
pole they're like okay it's gonna be
cold in full snow they don't really
realize that there's an arctic desert up
there
my name is daryn bearcloth i'm from
vancouver island british columbia and
i'm a professional mountain bike free
rider
free riding is all about picking your
own line and being free to interpret the
mountains in any way that you see fit
thinking about starting on the horizon
right there it'll be like a drop onto a
rock slab
the reason that we chose axel hybrid
island was because the lines were
massive it trumped anything that we ever
ridden before in terms of height and
just sheer scale
all right boys all right yeah boys epic
time
one of the hardest parts about that
whole trip was just as its remoteness
and how far it was from civilization
something goes wrong we're about 12
hours away in the best case scenario
from any hospital or serious health
the landscape up in the high arctic was
just it was breathtaking standing at the
top of the line just
soaking it all in it's
it's a pretty rad feeling
one thing that's amazing about mountain
biking is the fact that you can take it
anywhere you can climb mountains with it
you can descend mountains with it you
can travel long distances with it and
you can stuff it in a box and fly it
around the world
[Music]
to go up to the high arctic 400 miles
south of the north pole and ride my
bikes it's a pretty amazing thing to do
and check that off the bucket list for
sure
hey everybody my name is drew beebe and
i'm here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine
and i wanted to tell you about our new
podcast called great big story it's got
more surprising and delightful stories
just like this one so head over to apple
podcast to spotify wherever you get your
favorite podcasts and download great big
story